one two three four and five are the five
digits given to us and we have been
asked this how many five digit numbers
can be formed using these five digits
and we need to figure this out for two
cases when repetition is not allowed and
when repetition is allowed if you
haven't already I strongly recommend
that you go through our previous
sessions based on forming numbers it
will help you understand the session
much better okay let's understand what's
been asked in the first case we have
been asked to find the number of ways in
which five digit numbers can be formed
when repetition is not allowed okay
first things first let's make five slots
for the five digits is there any
condition given no there isn't we have
been asked for all five digit numbers
that can be formed using these five
digits as there is no condition we can
start from any end let's start with the
first slot in how many ways can the
first slot be filled we can fill it with
any one of the five digits correct yes
so there are five ways in which it can
be filled either a 1 or a 2 or a 3 or a
4 or a 5 now assume we have filled up
the first slot with one of these digits
with the first slot being filled in how
many ways can the second slot be filled
as one digit is used here four remain
the second slot can be filled in four
ways if the first slot is filled with a
four then the second one can be filled
with one two three or five if the first
slot is filled with a two then the
second one can be filled with a one
three four or a five now our students
have been used in the first two slots
the third one can be filled in three
ways similarly the fourth one in two
ways and the last one is just one way do
we multiply these or do we add them
don't forget the basic rules of counting
or is addition and is multiplication
as we are filling the first and the
second and the third slots and so on we
will be multiplying these five times
four is 20 20 times 3 is 60 and 60 times
2 is 120 there are 125 digit numbers
that can be formed using these five
digits provided repetition is not
allowed this is actually 5 factorial
many students memorize this five
distinct things can be arranged in five
factorial ways don't make that mistake
yes you may use 5 factorial directly
provided you understand why we use the
factorial here we saw it step by step y
5 y 4 and Y we multiplied them don't
memorize the factorial formula
understand the logic behind it and then
use it now let's move on to the second
part five digit numbers when repetition
of digits is allowed so we are allowed
to form numbers like 1 1 1 1 1 or 5 2 3
3 3 or 3 1 4 4 3 where digits are
repeated how do we begin as always we go
slot by slot the first slot can be
filled with any one of the five digits
it can be filled in five ways now I want
you to answer the next question having
filled the first slot with any one of
the digits in how many ways can the
second slot be filled as repetition is
allowed it doesn't matter which digit we
have filled in the first slot the second
slot can be filled in five ways again
why was it 4 in the previous case
because we cannot reuse the digit that
was used in the first slot in a similar
way the third fourth and the fifth slots
can also be filled in five ways each and
we multiply these as we are filling the
first and the second and the third slots
and
so on we get the answer as five raised
to five ways we can form these many five
digit numbers using these five digits
provided repetition is allowed these
problems are easy provided you
understand the logic of repetition let's
look at one last question in how many
ways can succeed be allocated to six
people assume that the six people are a
b c d e and f and imagine six chairs in
a row where these six people will be
seated how will you solve this in how
many ways can these six people be seated
on these six chairs pause the video and
try solving it think logically isn't
this the same as having six different
digits and being asked how many six
digit numbers can be formed of course
without repetition six different people
are analogous to six different digits
each number formed will be analogous to
each arrangement formed and it is
obviously without repetition as one
person cannot be seated on two or more
seats if one person is seated on chair 1
he cannot be seated on chair 2 as well
right and what will the answer be let's
go back to the previous page five digits
in five slots when repetition is not
allowed is this case 5 factorial going
back to the current problem the answer
to it will be 6 factorial 6 people can
be arranged on 6 seats in 6 factorial
ways here we have assumed that the seats
are in a row the answer will be
different if the seats are arranged in a
circular fashion don't worry about it
for now we have covered circular
arrangements in another session
you